ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ก็กลับมาพบกับครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูเอ๋แล้วก็
ครูหญิงก็กูอ่ะพ่อได้ชัด
ช่องนี้แหละค่ะครูเอ๋วันนี้วันอะไรครู
เหตุฐาน
วันนี้วันอะไรคะผู้หญิง
วันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะครูเอ๋วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 16 ค่ะ 6 แล้วเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
เมษายน
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพตต 2556
แต่ถ้าค่ะ
2565 ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีค.ศ
2000 ไม่ใช่
2  2 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะสงกรานต์ไปแล้วนะหมดแล้ว
ผู้หญิงตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้เวลา
16:00 น
57 นาที 4 โมง
57 นาทีนะคะไทยค่ะครูเอ๋หญิงเอ๋
ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋ Share  screen ทำไม
ผู้หญิงเห็นเนาะเห็นแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋แล้วนะ
คะเห็นแล้วค่ะเปลี่ยนสี up คะอันนี้ดี
กว่าปีมีเส้นให้กูเองนะคะไม่ได้คุยรู้
แล้วรู้แล้วเห็นว่าให้กินเก่งค่ะ
เอ่อคู๋มีสีเขียวนะคะให้ครูหญิงคิดครูเอ๋
ววาดอะไรมีเส้น 1 เส้นค่ะมีเส้นสีเขียว 1
เส้น 2 เส้นค่ะ
มีเส้นขีดแล้วก็ขึ้นไป
ง้อมีเส้นตรงมีเส้น
อะไรอ่ะอ่ะ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋เป็น
มีไปป์
ให้
ไปมันต้องเป็นต้นไม้เป็นต้นไม้ต้นอะไร
ต้นอะไรคะครูเอ๋
ให้ผู้หญิงให้ผู้หญิงดูผู้หญิงดูถ้าผู้
หญิงคิด
ผู้หญิงรู้แล้วครูหญิงรู้แล้วรู้แล้วหรอ
คะอ่า
อะไรคู่หญิงต้นนี้นะหมีแพนด้าชอบกิน
หมีแพนด้าหมีแพนด้า
กูมีใบเล็กมีใบใหญ่ด้วยหรอคะหน้าๆนี่ and
ด้า
อินน์ตรงไหนมีแพนด้ากินใบ
หมีแพนด้าเดี๋ยวกูเองบ้านหมีแพนด้าให้
เพิ่มมีแพนด้าเป็นยังไงครับตัวเองจะวาด
เหมือนไหม
เหมือนสิครูเอ๋เนี่ยชอบหมีแพนด้า
ไม่มีมีฉันได้ไม่เป็นไรไปว่าไข้
ลิตาตาหมีแพนด้า 4
ขอ
ให้ตามีแพนด้า
แพนด้าไม่นอน
ไม่นอน
นิสีดำใช่มั้ย
ดีสีดำกับสีขาวหมีแพนด้าหมีแพนด้านะคะมี
แฟนนะกูเอน่าสงสารมากกู a คะมีผู้หญิง
เห็นหมีแพนด้าครูเอ๋ครูหญิง
ทำไม
ไม่สวยหรอคะ
เอาใหม่เอาใหม่โอเคโอเค
ไม่ได้หมีแพนด้าสวย
ครูใหญ่ว่านมีแพนด้าใหม่ริตาแต่ถ้าหมี
แพนด้า 5 มีแพนด้าก็ต้องมีดำๆไงจ่ายค่ะ
มีตา
อิจฉา
จมูก
หุย
มีแพนด้าตัวนี้โอเคมีพันหน้า
อิ่มแล้วมีแผ่นด้านนอนหมีแพนด้ากินกินใบ
กินใบไม้อันนี้อิ่มอิ่ม
แล้วโอเคไหมหมีแพนด้าน้องโอโอเค
ไอ้ยิ้มก็ได้น่ะให้ยิ้มให้ยิ้ม
ในแผ่นได้กินอิ่มๆอ้าวโอเคมั้ยโอเค
ผู้หญิงจะได้รู้สึกสบายใจ
อยากสวยหมีแพนด้าอันนี้
ต้นไม้มีสีน่ะหมีแพนด้าเนี่ยอ้ะกิน
กินใบจะต้นนี้
[เพลง]
กินต้นอะไรคะผู้หญิง
ต้นชัยค่ะครูเอ๋ต้นไหมคะใช่ค่ะนอน
เก่งว่ามากหมีแพนด้ากินครูหญิงรู้ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงนักเรียนนักเรียนใส่หัว
ทำไม
มี
กินใบไผ่นะคะคนกินอะไรคะคนกินหน่อ
หน่อไผ่หรอคะหน่อไม้หน่อไม้
ต้นไผ่แล้วก็ข้อสอบไทยแต่เราจะพูดหน่อไม้
หน่อไผ่โอเคนะคะคนกินตรงวิอาหมีแพนดางกิน
อันนี้เอ้าๆครูเอ๋แล้วครูเอ๋ว่านต้นไผ่
ทำไมอ๋ออ๋อครูเอ๋ว่าต้นไผ่เพราะครูเอ๋
อยากจะบอกว่าคนไทยน่ะเอาต้นไผ่
ต้นไผ่นะอันนี้นะคะพร้อมใบเนี่ยไม่เอา
ลบอันนี้ก่อนนะกันได้ค่ะคนไทยเอาอันนี้
เลยค่ะ
ต้นไผ่หน่ะผู้หญิงไม่ใช่
คนไทยเอาต้นไผ่ต้นไผ่หน่ะ
มีมีดนะคนไทยมีมีดมี
ถ้า
ไม่มีมาทำอะไรคะมัดตัดตัดตัดต้นไผ่แล้วก็
เขาเรียกว่าริอัลมิตัดใบไม่เอาอ่ะเดี๋ยว
กูอื่นลบให้ละกัน
ลบไม่เอาหมีแล้วนะไม่เอาหมีค่ะไม่เอาอัน
นี้เอาไม่เอาไม่เอา
ไปไม่เอาค่ะใบไม่เอาอ้าวเหลือเฉพาะต้นไผ่
เอาไปทำอะไร
เอามาตัดคู่หญิงเอามาแล้วก็มีมีด
มี
พื้นนี่ก็ผ่า
ต้นไผ่ 1 ต้นรบผ่า
แล้วก็ผ่าแล้วก็ผ่าหน้ากากเหลาอย่างนี้
ทำไม
เราต้นเสื้อใส่หรอคะให้จากต้นไผ่ใหญ่ๆ
เป็น
เล็กๆสีเขียวดีกว่า
เอามีดผ่าผ่าผ่าแล้วก็เหลาเหลาต้นไผ่เล็ก
ๆใช่แล้วนะไข่เล็กๆต้นไผ่เวลาต้นไผ่ใหญ่ๆ
แข็งใช่ไหม
แข็งถ้าไม่
หัดไม่ได้พอจะใช้มีดมีดน่ะเหลาเหลาอ่ะกู
เห็นมีดมีดใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็เหลาเราๆเราจน
ต้นไผ่เล็กๆค่ะคนขายก็จะงอเห็นไหมฮะ
โอ้วจากแข็งๆง้อไม่ได้อ่ะอ่าเห็นไหมเห็น
อ้ะก็จะงอนอางอได้จะหักไหมเนี่ยหนูหาก็
กระเด็นใส่หน้านะกูอีกระวังอ่ะไปใส่หน้า
ผู้หญิงไม่เป็นไร
น้อ
อาจจะมีไว้นี่เห็นชอบติแจ้งอได้
นอนอ่ะอันนี้เป็นไม้บรรทัดเนี่ยเป็น
พลาสติกแล้วจะงอรอได้ค่ะ
ต้นไผ่เนี่ย
ต้นไผ่ก็จะ
งองอ
ได้แล้วเอาต้นไผ่ใหญ่ๆเราให้มันเล็กๆงอ
ได้ทำไมพอมีสั้นไผ่ขนาดเล็กๆหลายๆอันก็
เอามาเอามาทำเราเรียกว่าจะศาลเอามาสารสาร
สารเป็น
และของใช้อย่างเวลาเป็นของใช้
อันไกลเป็นของใช้คนไทยมีของใช้ทำจากต้น
ไผ่
หูมีอะไรบ้างนะครูเอ๋มีอะไรให้คู่หญิง
แชร์เลยค่ะได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงสถามครูเอ๋
ว่าอะไรๆเพราะว่ากู a ให้ผู้หญิงหาใจแล้ว
ค่ะคู๋มาเฟียทำจากต้นไผ่อ๋อของในรูปนี้ทำ
จากต้นไผ่เหรอคะในค่ะครูเอ๋คะแล้ว
เรียกว่าอะไรใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะเนี่ยไอ้ในรูป
เนี่ยเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋เข่งค่ะ
เก่ง
เก่งต้น
ถ้ามีอะไรคะคุณหูอันนี้ก็หู
หมูครูเอ๋ค่ะครูหญิงหูคนหูเข่งๆ
จับหู
อ๋อหูก็เอาไว้จับให้เอาไว้จับนะคะค่ะเวลา
ที่
ที่อะเดี๋ยววันที่บ้านใช่ไหมที่บ้านมีต้น
เห็นไหมคะเห็นค่ะต้นมะม่วง
มีมะม่วง
มะม่วงมากๆยิ่งเก็บเจ็บใส่เข่งอ๋อ
เข่งเอาไว้ใส่มะม่วงเหรอคะใส่มะม่วง
ใส่บล็อกค่ะเดี๋ยวพี่ใส่แครอทใส่ทุเรียน
โอเคโอ้ไว้ใส่ของค่ะนี้ใส่แล้วก็พอมีของ
ก็จับหู
หูเข่ง
หูแข่งไม่ใช่หัวผู้หญิงหนูแข่งจับหูอะแนะ
นะเดี๋ยวนักเลงวัดมือดีกว่า
มือ
จับหูแข่งๆมาน่ะ
กลับแล้วก็ยกขึ้น
ใหญ่ยกคนเดียวไม่ได้ก็ผู้หญิงข้างโน้นคุ่
ข้างนี้แล้วก็จับย้ง
ดีพี่ใช่โอเคอุ้ยดีอันนี้ไหมไผ่เนี่ยทำ
จากไม้ไผ่ใช่ไหมคะทำจากไหมไข่นะคะ
มี
ลูกยิงได้ค่ะ
มีอีกค่ะครูเอ๋โอ้
ในรูปของในรูปเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋ไซ
size ทำจากไม้ไผ่ใช่ไหมคะให้ค่ะ size
พูดได้ 2 อย่างนะ
พูด titan กับพูดยาวอยู่พูดสั้นใส่พูดยาว
ใส่ดักปลา
อ่อนมีปลา
ได้ต้องมีต้องมีน้ำไฟจะเอาไปที่น้ำค่ะไป
ที่น้ำใช่ฮะเราก็เอาซะจะใส่อยู่ในน้ำ
แล้วก็ข้างในจะมีมีอาหารอัดปลาชอบกินเอา
บราได้กลิ่นปลาก็จะมาที่นี่ปลาว่ายน้ำมา
อ่าก็เข้าไป
แล้วออกได้นะอ่อก็ดัดปลาเอาไปกินปลาก็จะ
อยู่ที่นี่
ปลาออกไม่ได้
แตกเวลาเราเวลาเราจะเอาปลาเราก็ต้องเปิด
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
เปิดแล้วก็เอาปลาออกมาแต่ปลาเนี่ยว่ายน้ำ
ออกไม่ได้ใส่ดัดปลาไปดักปลานะคะค่ะ
V ลบนะลบให้ได้ค่ะอ่าของต่อไป
มีอะไรคะโอ้โหอะไรคะครูเอ๋อ่า
กระจาดไปค่ะกราบจานทำจากอะไรคะทำจากไม้
ไผ่ค่ะเนี่ยไม้ไผ่นิไม้ไผ่อ่ะคุยจะวัดไม้
ไผ่ตลอด
สีเขียวดีกว่า
ไม้ไผ่ค่ะ
ไม้ไผ่
ไม้ไผ่ไม้ไผ่
นะฮะกระจาดกระจาดต้องทำจากทำจากไม้ไผ่ค่า
การ์ตูนไม้ไข่เอามาทำกระจากกระจาดทำจาก
ไม้ไผ่ OK ดีเหมือนกันค่ะพระจานใส่มะม่วง
ได้ไหมคะโอเคใส่ Apple ได้ไหมคะโอเคเอา
อะไร
โอเคนะ
มีอีกค่ะครูเอ๋มีอะไรคะหนูวุ้อะไรคะครู
เอ๋อา
โนเอเนี่ยเรียกกระชอนค่ะมีเรียกอย่างอื่น
เหรอคะครูเอ๋ไม่รู้แต่บ้านครูเอ๋เรียก
กระชอนคะ
กระชอนเนี่ยมีทำจากอะลูมิเนียมทำจาก
สแตนเลสอันนี้ทำจากไม้ไผ่ค่ะแล้ว
กระชอนทำอะไรใช้ทำอะไรอาทรณ์เนี่ยเวลากู
หญิงล้างอะไรใช่ไหมคะเรามีน้ำผู้หญิงก็
ใส่กระชอน
น้ำใหม่ๆ
ใส่หน้าโอ๋นะคะให้น้ำออกไปโอ้ไม่ไม่ต้อง
เท่ห์จะไม่หรอกพี่
หนาวหนูใหม่
เว่ยดีมากขลุ่ยไหมเคยเห็นกระชอนทำจากไม้
ไผ่งอกแตกกระชอนทำจากไม้ไผ่หน่ะเวลาใช้
เสร็จแล้วผู้หญิงต้องเอาไปข้างนอกแล้วก็
มี
พระอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคะค่ะพระอาทิตย์กับพระ
ขอตากแดดเหรอคะๆให้แห้งเพราะถ้ามีน้ำแล้ว
น้ำอยู่ที่นี่นานๆจะเป็น
สีดำแต่ขอเป็นสีดำเนี่ยไม่ได้ใช้ไม่ได้
แล้วเนี่ยไม่ไม่ได้เชื้อรายีสต์เชื้อรา
ต้องฉิง
โหใช้เสร็จก็ต้องตากแดด
ต่างแจกเชื้อราไม่มีค่ะ
เพราะว่าทำจากไม้ไผ่เนาะใช่ค่ะมีอีกมีค่ะ
ครูเอ๋
ในรูปเนี่ยอะไรคะครูเอ๋
กระด้งค่ะโหกระโดงนี่ใหญ่ไม่คะใหญ่แต่ไม่
ลึก
[เพลง]
กระชอนกระชอนเนี่ยเล็ก
ลึก
กระจาดเนาะประมาณนี้รถลึกเล็กแต่
มี
กระด้ง
อยู่ไหนมาแล้ว
กระโดงไม่ลึกนะคะค่ะหนู
คนไทยเมื่อก่อนอ่ะ
ก็ไม่จอดทำไม
เวลาเด็กๆ
[เพลง]
อยู่เวลาพ่อแม่คลอดลูกก็อยู่ในกระด้งนะ
เอาหรอคะเวลาถ้าครูหญิงท้องแล้วจะโอ้โห
โอ้ยเจ็บท้องแล้วก็
เด็กวางที่กระด้งฮือได้ยินได้ยินคู๋ได้
ยินว่า
ไว้นะไว้ในกระด้ง
แล้วจะอยู่ในกระด้ง
ค่ะอันนี้ก็กระโดงเนาะกระโดดลงจากกระโดง
นี้ทำอะไรได้มากๆหรอคะเมื่อนกเนี่ยอ่ะบาง
ทีมีข้าวก็ไว้ที่กระโดงมีปลา
ลาวัลย์ที่กระด้งได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะเอาปลา
แล้วก็
ก็มีแฝงอาทิตย์ปลาใหญ่ๆกับ
โอ๋แล้วก็เก็บนานๆกินนานๆ
กระโดงก็ทำจากไม้ไผ่ I ค่ะน่ะมีอีกค่ะครู
เอ๋มีอะไรคะอะไรคะครูเอ๋อาอ่ากระติ๊บอ๋อ
อ๋อกระติ๊บนี่เล็กๆคุยคะหรือว่าใหญ่ๆมี
ตั้งแต่เล็กค่ะนางใหญ่ๆหนู
ระติ๊บทำจากไม้ไผ่ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
กะติ๊กเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะผู้หญิงเอาไว้ใส่
ข้าวเหนียวเมื่อเดี๋ยวกูเอหารูปให้ผู้
หญิงมีค่ะไม่มีไม่มีท่านผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงต้องถามเหมือนกูเอกใช่ไหมคะผู้
หญิงหาค่ะนี่ค่ะครูเอ๋แล้วมีมากใส่ค่ะนี่
ค่ะ
กาติ๊บใส่แล้วเอาเหนียวนี่เข้าเหนียวใน
ข้าวเหนียวข้าวเหนียวก็ 1 แถวนั้นหอมเนาะ
ของ
มีส้มตำข้าวเหนียวซาอยาก
จะวิ่งไปซื้อข้าวเหนียว
ศาสตร์
ครูเอ๋กระติ๊บเสร็จแล้วมีอีกไหมคะดีอีก
ค่ะอุ้ยอะไรคะครูเอ๋ในรูปก๋วยซ่อม
ผู้หญิงรู้ผู้หญิงรู้นะคะเรียกว่าอะไร
คือเต่าไหมคะกระเป๋าได้กระเป๋าก็ได้นะ
พี่เก๋
ผู้หญิงก็เป็นกระเป๋าได้ผู้หญิงก็เอา
โทรศัพท์ใส่โอเคเอาเงินเงินใส่โอเคโอ้
โอ้โหเป็นกระเป๋าใส่โทรศัพท์
ใส่เงินเหรอคะครูเอ๋
เรียกว่าอะไรเรียกว่าคล่องค่ะช่องใส่อะไร
ถ้าไม่ใช่ใส่โทรศัพท์
ไอปลา
มีปลา
อ่ะใส่อะไรดีล่ะมีปลามีกบกบกบ
ต้องสีเขียวใช่ไหมอันขาดอ๊อฟๆ
จบอบๆให้คุยแล้วคุย
ไม่ไหมมี
ผู้หญิงยังเห็นพี่ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นน่ะครูเอ๋
[เพลง]
กบโอเคโอเคกบออก
อากาศจับกบแล้วก็ใส่จับกบแล้วก็ใส่จับปลา
ใส่ขอใส่ในคล่องใส่ข้างในน่ะใส่
ในคล่องเอาแล้วอันนี้อะไรคะครูเอ๋ฝาปิด
คล่องหอไม่ให้กบกระโดดออกให้
กบใส่กบใส่ปลาแล้วไม่ปิดกบอ่ะ
วิ่ง
กระเป๋าจริงๆเลย
กระเป๋าใส่ปลาไม่ใช่ห้องชื่อของ
ค่ะมีอีกเกรดสอบที่บ้านกูอ่ะโอ้นี่นะเวลา
ครูเอ๋ไปบิ๊กซีโลตัสดีคอง
สายอาจมีอีกค่ะครูเอ๋มีอะไร
อุ้ยอะไรคะครูเอ๋
ชะลอม
ชะลอมใส่ใส่กบมีกบแล้วก็ใส่ไม่ใส่นะใส่
ไข่
ไก่มะม่วงโอเคคนไทยเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมคะ
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยเวลาสมมติครูเอ๋จะไปหา
สมัครไปบ้านผู้หญิงกูเอกมีมะม่วงมะม่วง
มะม่วงใส่ชะลอม
แล้วก็ถือ
ผู้หญิงครูเอ๋มีกี่มะม่วงมาให้หนึ่ง
ขอบคุณค่ะครูเอ๋โอ้
โหไปรอมใส่ของที่เอาไปให้
น้องสวยนะเวลาดู
น้องทำสาดไม้ไผ่อันนี้อันนี้ก็ฉลอมใช่ไหม
คะไปค่ะชะลอมเหมือนกันค่ะอะต่อไปอะไรคะ
อีกอันนี้ทำจากไม้ไผ่ไหมกูเอ๋
อันนี้ทำจากหวายนะ
ทำจากหวายและเป็นเครื่องจักสาน
ใครๆไม้ไผ่แต่ไม่ใช่มั้ยไผ่เรียกว่าหวาย
นี้เป็นต้นไม้เหรอคะครูเอ๋ไม้เล็กๆแต่ตัว
นี้งอได้งอได้แต่บางคนก็ใช้ไม้ไผ่ผู้หญิง
น้องพ่อหวายแพงหวายจะแพงบางคนก็เอาไม้ไผ่
มาทำราคะมีจากไม้ไผ่ก็จะจากอ่ะหวายอันนี้
ไหมคะหวายอ่านชายหวายคล้ายๆไม้ไผ่เนาะอัน
นี้ครูเอ๋ไม่แน่ใจเพราะดูไม่ชัดนะหวายไหม
ไข่เนี่ยเราก็เอามาทำเอามาแล้วทำทำเนี่ย
พูดว่าจักสานเหมือนกันหารกันก็เป็น
เครื่องจักสาน
อันเนี้ยเรียกว่าตะกร้อเพราะตาร้อ
และก็น่ะเพราะสอยมะม่วงสอยมะม่วง
พี่เอ๋แล้วง่วงก็จะอยู่ในนี้คุยกันโอเคกู
หญิงไว้ก็ได้ค่ะอ๋อเราก็มะม่วงก็อยู่ใน
ตะกร้อลงมาชายแล้วก็ลงมาเก็บมะม่วง
แล้วก็สอยๆปล่อยมะม่วงเอกชอบแต่ก็ถ้าตก
เก่งใช่ๆ
เก่งนะส่อยมะม่วงเนี่ย
มีอีกค่ะครูเอ๋มีอะไรคะนี่ค่ะเรียกว่า
อะไรคะครูเองนิดตะกร้าค่ะอ๋อตะกร้าวันนี้
ไปช้อปปิ้งได้มั้ยได้ถือตะกร้าแล้วเดิน
เดินๆ
Emporium เอ็มวันนี่
เดอะมอลล์โอเคไหมคะจานอ่าโอเคจ๋ารัก
เรียนนักเรียนโอเคครูหญิงไม่โอเคเอามั้ย
ก็นักเรียนไม่ใช่คนไทยถือตะกร้าแล้วก็
ช้อปปิ้งคนไทยเห็น
ว้าว
ครูหญิงถือตะกร้าแล้วไปช้อปปิ้งราคาคนไทย
คิดอ่อ
ไม่มีเงิน
ไม่รู้เขาเรียกว่าคนต่างจังหวัด
นิกเกิลไทยไปวัดนะตัวเองวัดไปวัดจะกล้า
เนี่ยเวลาที่เราอันนี้วะ
อยู่บ้านน่ะ
มาร์ช
[เพลง]
ไปวัดนะคะ
อ่ะเราก็ทำอาหารน่ะก็มีอาจจะมีนี่เป็น
ข้าว
เป็น
มีอะไรไม่รู้
อันปิ่นโตอาหารมีผลไม้
ก็ใส่แต่กล้าแล้วก็คิวแล้วก็เดินไปวัดหู
แกนไปที่วัดนะค่ะสาดแม่
ไม่ใช่ๆ
แปลว่าครูเองไม่ถือตะกร้าไปพารากอนไปอ่า
อะไปไปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต 7 ไม่ถือเพราะว่ามัน
ใหญ่ให้น่ารักพับพับพับไม่ได้ๆแต่ถ้าครู
เอ๋ไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วครูเอกต้องไป
ตลาดโอเคคุยเอาปากกล้าเพราะตลาดคนไทยตลาด
แอบถ่ายไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยโอเคใส่ใส่
ตะกร้าแล้วก็หิ้วแล้วก็ขึ้นรถแล้วกลับ
บ้านอ่ะนี้โอเคอ๋อแบบไทยคิวจะกล้าแล้ว
ขึ้น
BTS  MRT
แท็กซี่โอเค
ตะกร้าก็ทำจากไม้ไผ่น้องวันนี้เราก็ให้
นักเรียนดูน้องหารู้จักนะเครื่องจักสานคน
ไทยดูอีกหนึ่งครั้งนะคะฟังอีก 1 รอบอะไร
คะครูหญิงตะกร้าต่อไปค่ะ
ตัดกร้อกลับไปค่ะอะไรคะ
ชะลอม
อะไรคะช่อง
คล่องโอเคต่อไปนะมีช่องกระติ๊บกลับไปค่ะ
อะไรคะ
ระดองกลับไปค่ะอะไรคะราชอน
ต่อไปค่ะอะไรคะ
กระจาดต่อไปค่ะอะไรคะไปไปต่อไปค่ะอะไรคะ
เฮงเฮงต่อไปค่ะไม่มีแล้วหมดแล้วผู้หญิง
เก่งมากจำได้นะคะ
เรื่องจักสานได้นะคะโอเคค่ะคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋
กับผู้หญิงไปแล้วค่ะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้า
นะคะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย